es ist das letzte hurra der anhänger von
donald trump zehntausende marschierten
samstag durch washington dc beim großen
make america droht der entzug
dabei hat der präsident gerade die
wiederwahl verloren einige rufen for
more years vier weitere jahre das tram
verloren hat glaubt hier niemand
stattdessen wird gegen den angeblichen
riesigen wahlbetrug demonstriert
die transportpolizisten aufstellung
genommen und eben dahinter dass dieses
fordern mehr von trump anhänger und auf
der anderen seite in diesem niemandsland
sozusagen sieht man demonstraten der
vergleichsmiete bewegung ebenfalls
ausgestattet mit schildern
natürlich es gibt hier weit weniger von
dieser gruppe sind ungefähr vielleicht
50 leute auf der anderen seite natürlich
tausende transporters und es ist eine
stimmung die zum zerreißen ist
eigentlich es ist eine stimmung die an
einem pulverfass erinnert jeden moment
kann hier die gewalt ausbrechen so
jedenfalls fühlen die menschen
trump ist auch vor ort er lässt sich an
den massen vorbeifahren
lisette ist mit ihrer familie gekommen
sie sagt warum sie da ist erstens für
unser land zweitens für meine kinder
und drittens für unseren präsidenten
trump
bereits am vorabend der make america
gegendemo kam es zur rangelei mit linken
gegendemonstranten polizisten der
washington metropolitan police mussten
einschreiten alarmierend in die menge
mischte sich ein fast 100 mann starkes
kontingent der rechtsextremistischen
braut boys außerdem immer wieder mit
dabei männer in tarnkleidung und
schusssicheren westen
beobachter rechnen damit dass trump die
bilder des massen aufmarsches ermutigen
dürften
er könnte sich bestärkt fühlen den
beiden sieg weiter anzufechten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren